all right and we are live the last word
lord cognito ibontes thai guy travis
fresh on that thursday evening campfire
special guest so we are not gonna waste
any time e how you doing real quick uh
doing excellent gcx was amazing but we
got a special guest travis how you doing
good gcx
tom
good to see you guys all right let's get
this thing started let's get this thing
started here we go welcome to the last
word episode number 202
tonight is a very special episode
because we are joined by one of the
wizards behind the scenes of destiny 2.
like many of us he has been playing
video games since he could sit upright
from castlevania to counter-strike his
tastes were varied but it helped him
find his path in life this man started
his journey making games back in the ps2
era with the world's favorite web
slinger in spider-man 3.
he has been an integral part of day one
studios
robomoto and even ea before he landed at
bungie more than 10 years ago those who
have worked alongside him have nothing
but praise for his enthusiasm knowledge
and passion he brings to every studio he
has worked at in his 10 years at bungie
we have this man and the many teams he
has worked with to thank for destiny 1's
moon and mars destinations the opening
missions in destiny 2's red war campaign
a three-week cycle in the dreaming city
and seasons of dawn opulence arrivals
chosen spicer the 30th anniversary and
now season of the haunted so let's
welcome a true hunter at heart a
boilermaker from indiana one who enjoys
a wide variety of movies from spaceballs
to everything everywhere all at once a
man who has a wide variety of food
tastes from kimchi as a snack to a can
of sardines with lunch
is in he draws inspiration from all
sorts of games but even franchises close
to my heart like zelda and mario it's
been quite a journey for this man who
was a fan of bungie as a player and
completed the halo campaign in one
sitting to recently getting to drop the
bomb of news as a developer at the same
studio that the beloved gallahorn was
coming back to destiny 2. so let's hear
it for the one the only creative lead at
bungie tom farnsworth how you doing sir
excellent that's that's hard to follow
up here that's a great intro like you
guys are really good at this and no i
it's
it's really great to be here and i you
know i've been at bungie a little while
now or just uh just a few years here and
it's and uh just a minute and
i
i really want to thank you for inviting
me let me be here today to talk about uh
seasonal haunted and you know a little
bit by myself too maybe yeah no i mean
first thing i did want to start with
before we get into the seasonal stuff is
i just kind of want you to explain to
the audience and everybody who hears
this what it is you do at bungie as a
creative lead and you know maybe a
couple steps along the journey but what
is your role at the company at least for
now
yeah so at the currently my role i'm a
creative lead on our seasonal team uh
the team is codenamed vanguard
and we have two teams alpha and omega
and i'm the creative lead for vanguard
alpha so
uh basically i take our business goals
our uh kind of creative leadership goals
what we think players are excited about
what you all really want out of destiny
as and what uh
we we are trying to make you happy with
what we're building surprise and delight
y'all and then what the team is excited
about and trying to find that
intersection between like you know what
what can we do
uh that what can we afford to do and
what are we really excited as it's
creatively uh put together for y'all
nice nice nice so we're gonna get right
into these uh questions so yeah you want
to take it off there with the next one
yeah let's jump off man so you know
you're this huge veteran in bungie 10 10
year in the game and um obviously season
haunted is here but what i want to talk
to you is kind of like the uh the annual
expansion kind of versus the seasonal
releases and um kind of what the
challenges you face obviously you guys
switched to that model and um as far as
like trying the challenge as far as
trying to make enough content and also
like does the dcv the destiny content
vault become a factor when you're making
seasonal content
so i'll start with the challenges for
the annual versus the seasonal so the
the annual like we've got obviously a
team that's
devoted just to that and they're kind of
like off planning that and i think in
terms of the seasons like our biggest
challenge with because we're on the
seasons team is like just trying to line
it all up right like they've got this
you know like they're kind of like the
blockbuster movie and we're kind of like
the serial tv show and we have to really
work with them to line up what that
through line is for the year that's that
takes a lot of work it's really taken us
i think if you look past the
last three years like it's only like
since like season 13 like i think you
all started to really feel like oh
bungie's got this plan like we're
sitting down like like at all and all
this makes sense and like we i think
this year it's been even stronger right
we've got that was really strong
handshakes with those teams and the
narrative team is just kicking butt
which is awesome
and um so that's really
uh been something that it's taken up a
number of years for us to get good at
and and we're i think we're pretty
secure in that space now
in terms of like the the content vault
side of things right i think there's a
a few ways you can look at that right
there's like raids which we just kind of
like we pull them out of the vault we
upgrade them to match the sandboxes the
destiny 2 sandbox now is
different than the destiny 2 sandbox
when it started for
yeah yeah for those of you who've been
here with us like you know dual weapons
versus like solar 3.0 right now uh it's
a pretty big delta so we have to do a
lot of updating and work and to bring
those things out of the vault where i
think if you look at like season 17 what
we're doing is we're kind of like we're
not really bringing something out of the
vault we're like remixing or evolving
something right we want like that's more
like the live side of things where we
want to evolve the world and we want to
take something like the leviathan and
use it to tell a really cool part of the
story like you know callus is back we he
we uh some our narrative staff and our
team that came up with this idea for
pressage right many many seasons ago and
season 13 that and that was like an idea
that came from the team that did not
come from me or the creative leadership
team like our writers and the designers
in a brainstorm we're like what if we
did something that was like event
horizon what if what the ship came back
wrong and that was pressage and then
that became you know that mission and
then now like a year later it became a
season and that's one thing i one thing
i really like about working at bungie
the creative process and like
from that idea then we were able to look
at like oh what if leviathan came back
wrong what if like leviathan was haunted
and so i think that this is kind of
around that back up then it's like yeah
we're gonna pull things out of the vault
and update them and we're gonna also
like find really cool ways to evolve a
world that makes sense for where we're
going with the narrative
so i don't know travis
yeah so um between seasons we've had
lots of different types of events and
lots of different types of content from
you know uh our
unmatch made public events uh kind of
that you guys did earlier seasons too
stuff like expunge and severed and uh
the leviathan patrol so we've seen lots
of different types of seasonal content
what decides for your team kind of the
scale of the season is the limitation
how much time you guys have because
obviously that's a factor with the fact
that you guys have to roll these out so
frequently
is it thematic elements where you're
really just doing whatever you need to
to serve the story or is it something
else that players don't even really know
about or take into consideration
i think it
anymore we've been trying to like plan
things out longer for just to give the
team the time it needs so we're not
reacting we're like you know we're
building to a plan and that means we're
kind of looking at like each season like
next to the next so we can have some
contrast and variety i think like at a
high level uh at a lower level
we also kind of have these like you know
frameworks that we've built like you
know like a cool six player thing and
then battlegrounds
and there'll be times like season 17
where we do something new we try to do
like a seasonal destination and we take
a risk and
um we we try to uh build a new loop wave
like like we have where like free
players can go to the destination they
can get they can do the public event
they can get opulent weapons but paid
players can also do kind of a weekly
mission like we've normally done so
there's things that are familiar there
and they're things that are
new and i think you'll always find that
like we're going to be
kind of trying to straddle like uh
like i think as you mentioned like we're
always trying to balance like what is
new versus like what we're building on
uh from the past and but i think if you
like season the season it might not seem
like much but if you step back and look
like two or three years ago like we've
evolved a lot over over season this
season and like we didn't even have
seasonal storytelling like we have now
until like season 11 it was like part of
that and then you know then like the
best we could do was which was great at
the time um we had the heiress moments
where you would go to the tree and you
talked to harris right and that was our
first little like oh what if we did this
every week we did a little story beat
and then season 13 a few seasons just
two seasons later we're like what if
every week we had like a serialized
story like mandalorian where every week
i'm excited to walk in and i think so
you're going to see like incremental
changes and every once in a while you'll
see a big leap where like all sudden
you're like oh aha here's something
that's new
yeah yeah
one of the things that um
you guys tried out was doing those live
events like when the uh
the space station crashed into the tower
and we were all there watching it kind
of float down yes we we haven't seen
that since does that was that an idea
that you guys hoped to pursue and the
moment just hasn't arrived yet or was
there a reason you kind of left it off
the table recently or
i think the part of it is you have we
have to find a moment where it makes
sense for the story and like there
really needs to be something of that
scale like where we can set it it's hard
to set up like world-ending events over
and over and over and it's like it's
tiring
every season it's like who's the bad guy
it's like no it's like what if what if
we did a political story this season and
it was about the fallen like so i think
that was a great season shout out to
like she mean she was out here she was
watching
she had her ideology all right
oh her
uh her voice actress is oh she's so good
too i love her
she's oh my god the raspberry oh i love
that voice good thing sorry yeah and
like there's very few things that i get
to like help with and that julia
ultimately made because our narrative
lead ultimately made the decision for
that but like we had definitely like had
earmarked we're like we're getting we're
bringing shore back even though we ended
up killing the character off but
and then we did an episode over a
screenshot of her lying dead so yeah
that's how we felt about that about that
sorry i kind of sidetracked there no no
no
that's all good so you've been involved
in so many seasons and you've been with
bungie had different roles in things
at your level now being the creative
lead but you work with many teams what
is
do you have like a favorite
piece of it is it like the creation
process is it when you start to finally
kind of mesh out what the activities are
what are your favorite pieces of
actually just making a season since
you've made so many
so
like my job evolves
over the course of the calendar project
right every season goes from like a
pitch through like kind of a
pre-production production and
post-production to launch and then live
support and at the same time we're you
know we're supporting that we're already
like pitching and working on the next
thing so it's kind of like it was relay
race and then you've got another team
over there and together we're doing this
complicated dance um my my main creative
input is the pitch because like that's
where i like i go to robbie stevens
who's my lead and our larger leadership
group joe everybody and they're like tom
these are the goals we want you to build
a season about a hacker or something
kind of like that
and
and like try to find a way to make that
work in destiny then i go to our
narrative lead our art director and
other people and then our designers i'm
like what is a hacker and destiny and
they're like tom it's a spicer i'm like
oh that makes sense uh like and how do
we make this work with the plot and like
they're like oh we're gonna have
this
we need to have something with this
political story about the fallen and
we're bringing these these new factions
in uh
it's gonna be a changing uh world in
destiny right like we're gonna evolve
the story season over season and then i
have to kind of like figure out like oh
like what's the threat this season like
and then someone was like what if the
power went out i'm like what if it was
an endless night and and like and then
i'm trying to shop those ideas around
and make them work and get feedback from
people and then push like basically boil
that down into a big powerpoint deck
and make make terrible designer concept
art and get really good concept art from
my art director uh figure out what the
rewards are what the activity structure
is like yeah it's gonna be a six player
activity and like a three-player
activity we usually build like a grind
activity and we build like a story
activity like
for the season
um and
that's really where i'm spending the
most time but i it's not me i want to
like make sure everyone knows like i'm
just there to collect everyone's idea
and make sure the best ideas survive and
the the worst ideas kind of get pushed
out of the way and a lot of the best
ideas don't cover me like like pressage
did not
come from leadership and this season
like season of the haunted the best idea
like some of the best ideas like when we
pitched this season like it didn't have
a scythe in it i was like it's gonna be
about reapers and everyone's like what
if we did a scythe and i was like
it's like i was like you're like
yes so we're gonna do that and so it's
really creative leads at bungie and
leaders at bungie the higher you go the
bigger the box that you're given
the bigger the challenge and it's your
job to break those into smaller pieces
and go to the team and find the best
ideas and like get really good at and
then putting it putting that into your
design and leveling it up so that's
really my favorite part is like working
with the team and like getting their
best best ideas and bringing it all to
you now i just want to hear all the
worst ideas i want to do a whole lot
on ideas all the time
most of my ideas my first pitch it's
like
it's like not that good so is there is
there a memorable like bad idea that you
could yeah can we get one we get one
i mean
that could have happened
we get it but yeah
um let me see some bad ideas i'm trying
to think here so
there are there are often like
bad ideas that we can turn into good
ideas like we often want to do like joe
had a read about this other day uh like
we want to do cute things and on an
alpha like we like try to get like
something fun or mimi in there and like
star horse is something i think that
could have been bad
but like
we initially
uh when we were working on that for 30th
uh like i was talking to luke and other
people like what we need a character for
this but we want it to be like fourth
wall breaking and weird
uh but like
like whatever was the horse
and
and it seemed like and then for a while
like i even like i took it out of the
deck i was like i don't
me i don't maybe i don't want to put
that in front of people and then luke
was like no tom put it back in there
it's gonna be funny and i was like
you're right you're right about that and
then i went to nick artisone who's our
was our lead writer on that i was like
could you what would it be like if the
horse
talked and he's like i got this tom and
he came back with the whole like what
you see right now in the game show right
like zur says some dry line
and then star horse racks yeah and then
the three reacts which is like the
classic it's like it's almost a groot
it's like group like from uh
and then i knew we had something good
but until then i was like totally on the
fence and then with 30th we had the game
show fantasy and that was the thing
where like we didn't lean into it really
hard and after he uh i got that back
from nuke it's like okay lean really
hard into this and that's where we ended
up getting like the ridiculous quotes
from like game shows that
i hadn't even heard of some of them uh
yeah so like that's probably the best
example was like star horse was pretty
weird
this is this is amazing man
yeah so far y'all just gotta say just
you know with all that and you know
we're talking narrative and it's clear
you guys are firing all cylinders it's
for me as a destiny fan it's really cool
to see because i've been criticized for
loving this game for so long and and the
joke was how could you let this game it
has no story like this is from like way
back for people who don't play the game
consistently but to their defense at the
time the narrative wasn't where it is
now so to see it all come together now
season of the haunted now we got these
really deep emotional connections
several stories right that are really
really entrenched in getting deep so
like
i know you've explained like the process
of how it works within the overall
arching story how you guys have to
collaborate almost like tune in next
week you know kind of a deal but like
how is it to really focus now on these
truly emotional bits with sever and
seasonal haunted
yeah i mean
with this the narrative team
really came in that they wanted to
address
the nightmares and from shadow keep in a
new and compelling way and they wanted
to do it through the lens of these
characters that we'd grown attached to
like you know the zabala and uh crow and
cayetal and really be able to show
new depth to those characters right like
before this week like i don't know
there's like the the zavala stuff this
past few weeks has been incredible right
like like and like i take no credit for
any of that it gets all the narrative
team and their hard work and i i i mean
i also want to say that like you know
mental health is you know a real
challenging space for i mean for all of
us right now in the world but even for
this
most people have suffered some trauma in
their life so they're
it is relatable in that way and that i
think the best stories are
relatable and human
and the narrative team i think there's
some articles out right now that uh
robert brooks kind of spoke to some of
his own personal experiences of dealing
with trauma and like so i think a lot of
the reason why it resonates and it's
working is because people are really
speaking from a place of experience
there and
with a lot of care
uh for these characters and um
i think
like that's really what excites me about
people that kind of build a skeleton or
a framework and for a season and hand it
to our writers or to our designers or
artists because they can really be the
ones that like to make make these things
say
very cool very cool i feel it like i
said it's just been it's a pleasure
every week because i get excited you log
in on reset and it's like you see the
little flash and i go over to the hell
okay what's happening this week the same
thing with prior seasons you know it's
always been especially the sabbath dudes
i gotta give credit too like i love that
like i she i i wasn't comfortable
visiting her
cool kind of thing because i wanted to
know what manipulative things she was
going to say and who she was going to
affect so i thought that was interesting
but
shout out to the entire team you guys
are killing it with the narrative
thank you
does the seasonal group also are they
also responsible for
like stuff like the dungeon
duality were you guys involved in
duality or is that sort of a separate
team because i know raids are a separate
team we collaborate with them so like
when like you can obviously look at
duality and the season right and they
are kind of under the same creative
space they're under leviathan and that
was something that our creative goals
were trying to do we wanted to tell a
larger story and
um our narrative staff was which was
shared across that so like you can you
can see there's but there's like idols
and zwalis and crow side of the story
and there's calluses side of the story
um but all all the raids and dungeons
are done by the raids and dungeon team
which internally we call rad so rad raid
and dungeon yeah
pretty cool i mean
it's pretty cool
um and they're amazing right they're
great partners and like being able to
have like
them delivering content like every
season is just huge i think for players
and and for us because like like i
i still have some of my fondest memories
of playing destiny are still of getting
my friends together
and getting into like vaulted glass
and like guiding people through their
first time and getting my mythic class
like after after like failing for hours
and dying like oh we're gonna quit and
um so like they really are a great
incredible point and just like yeah it's
nice now i'm imagining the raid and
dungeon team skateboarding into the
bungee office every day because they're
the rad group
so so uh
but now now this is sort of new which is
raids and dungeons have stories now
which obviously impacts you and the
seasonal team especially since there's
not only thematic overleap but overlap
but there's story overlap so how do you
guys parse things like working on
mechanics and the games part of a
dungeon with like the story and because
obviously the most recent raid is super
story heavy and has huge implications on
the future of destiny's narrative the
current dungeon that we're dealing with
uh ties a lot into the story of this
season so what is that collaboration
like when you have to make
gameplay and story kind of collide
so brian frank spoke to us a bit last
week and some of the maybe some articles
and press coming up this week but like
they they start from like a really
simple theme and like duality like it's
writing the name right sure like and
like the the two worlds the two split
spaces and we've kind of done
versions of that before like dreaming
city and the the strike with uh the
corrupted strike where like we kind of
went back and forth between that one
reality and another in the ascendant
plane but like what if we did it in a
way that players had control and like
that was really the problem space
that brian had given to the team was
like what yeah what if we take this
mechanic all the way and they also
uh worked with the narrative team to
really like understand like okay like if
we're going in and out of this place
what is it is it a nightmare like yeah
that sounds like awesome it's like it's
right in line with the same theme of the
season and that's how they're kind of
dipping their toes into what we were
doing and we because like we were like
okay you can do anything in the
leviathan you can do anything with the
shadow keep nightmares or anything with
the pressage stuff and i think they did
a pretty good job of like you kind of
start with the pressage vibe and then
you work your way into the nightmare
vibes uh and then they told
because we have the shared narrative
staff the narrative team could really
kind of like
make it so like the seasonal story is
contained and the dungeon story is
contained but together they tell a
larger story like so you don't have to
experience one or the other
uh but if you do you get a richer
understanding of the world
awesome
uh yeah so i wanted to kind of ask
because you take say like which queen
and season of the risen you get a big
expansion you get a season that comes
with those
and then you get the next following
season
i wanted to ask you what it's like to
decide because in destiny there's always
the joke of there's a lot of stories uh
kind of up in the air
with regards to
how do you decide what to tell next i
mean is it planned way far back cause he
said trying to make that through line
and just what is that like process to
decide how is this story gonna make it
all the way through a year how far do
you step away from it because as you
kind of decided as you as you mentioned
um
you have
the big blockbuster movie and then you
have the syndicated tv show and then
even in syndicated tv shows you have
like the filler episodes which i would
not call it not calling a season that
but you have like then you have like the
big over arcs and stuff like that so
so it's like how do you how do you
decide what story to tell and when i
guess that's the question i'm getting to
yeah
i mean we have
over the past few years we've really
built up the narrative organization and
destiny and our lead their leadership
group is like kind of like steering
you know like i think if you really like
refer to like you know
the fact that we put the road map out
for the next several
annual releases right like they have the
plan i don't always have the plan but
that they have it
and they're working towards very
specific uh goals and points and
there are times in the season where it's
like oh it would be cool like if we
picked up this this thread or there are
times where like i think if you look at
seasonal haunted you can say like yeah
they they wanted to bring certain
characters back in the story like we
wanted a callus and others to be part of
what's going on
this season but they didn't say it
needed to be
in the leviathan they didn't need to say
it needed to be
with these characters so there's a
certain amount of it is like the
leadership picks so like a bullet point
list of things they would like
okay and like at a very high level
that's where the road map is it's just a
it's just a set of bullet pointed lists
that like our goals and constraints or
just you know
seeds of an idea and then that goes to
our our leadership team and the the
leadership teams on the seasonal team
we're on the annual teams and then we're
like what could those be and then we you
know then we work through our pitch and
we hand it back up to them and we're
like is that okay
and and they might be like change those
things and then we we after a few
iterations we get to a place where we're
happy with it and then we pitch it and
we build it
so you guys are the improv team and
you're getting suggestions from the
audience that's what you're saying
yeah i get a suggestion from the
audience all right let's do it
because we we here at the warlock
delegation would like to know if osiris
is going to get a bullet point one day
because oh boy oh my god you know we
just you know at some point i guess i'm
saying it just obviously i'm a big boy i
get a big oscillator but my question is
are those
you say you almost like a submittal to
the team saying okay this is what we're
thinking about these are characters we
think about using it is there ever some
push pull but like hey we really would
like to use this character i mean
the overarching tv series might say not
yet final shape y'all we got some things
we want to do hey we're not ready for
you okay i've been speaking for for
julie a little bit here but yeah casting
is always interesting because we only
get so many voices and then sometimes
you can't get an actor right if you
can't get an actor in because they get a
movie or a tv show like you have to
change your past up and that that
changes everything yeah and then like
sometimes we want to kill a character
off because we want to have stakes like
we did uh in in season the spicer and
like that's a big deal like to kill a
character and like so they often or
three full factions in your case
or three hole fashions you can play
i'll take playing for that the purple
ball and drop pods you can put those all
on me too yeah
i'm going to
put a face to the blame it's fine yeah
and that one
in that season the character he chose to
kill was you
you're you yeah
every time a drop pod kills somebody i i
don't an angel doesn't get their wings
but maybe
yeah i guess i just drink your tears you
got a bonus i guess
um you did it for the glimmer uh yes
a question i have is it so in it like
most bungee devs i've talked to and i've
had the you know the pleasure of going
to bungie hq a lot to do coverage um
they are all destiny players which is a
very weird experience because you see
them in their pr hat and then after the
event you go and you have a beer with
them and they're just like talking about
how they got to go home and grind which
is kind of crazy right so everyone on
this podcast as well as every guest
we've ever had has had pet projects that
we wish destiny would just like take on
for example my pet project is making a
ranking system a ranked tiered system
like broccoli
putting that in
so my question is what it you're also a
destiny fan which means i know you've
got pet projects things that you wish
destiny would add on you know cog i
think it's like adding srl back in the
game i don't know people have people all
have these pet projects what is your
thing that you just as a fan wish that
that bungie would would just decide you
wish that a note would come from those
higher-ups that had a bullet point that
said go and work on this you wish that
it was that i think we already got the
ones in that i wanted like over the past
few years trying to get to this like a
serial story like over the weekend that
that's didn't all come for me right like
that's the thing that came from our
narrative group it came from our leads
it came to like from us just like trying
to like can we actually build this like
that's something i've been really
happy about um
there's things that as a hunter i want
but i can't get so like a
play hunter um no i mean
so this is like
i love what our sandbox team is doing
but i just i played d1 i just remember
arc blade back in the day and and i like
and i like void blade and like spectral
blades like that's cool but just like i
remember at a certain point and taken
king where
i was i had like a hopscotch pilgrim and
a shotgun
and um
like another heavy weapon and i had just
mastered that play style and then taking
king came out it all changed and
then
and also i've gotten older i'm like four
boys now and i just have never gotten
that good again so i need to like
i still play a lot um
but i i wish i had the time to get back
to play at that level again and
understand the sandbox at that level
because like working on a game for 10
years and and playing it for 10 years
it's been crazy like i never thought i
would do this can i and all the other
studios i worked at for a bunch it was a
year or two and
yeah
very sorry so blade dancer returning
confirmed listeners
he leaked it he liked it i mean
megan that's just me as a player from a
long time ago exactly
i'm joking compartmentalization is key
there yeah
you got one more
yeah i mean it's just it's just it's
it's so cool to see the evolution you
know and um to see where you guys are
going with this thing and you know one
thing that i find interesting and me and
travis talked about it from the whole
we took obviously we talked story we
talked about expansion we talked about
saboteur and and then we got rock and
the witness and stuff like that and to
know that there is that long-term plan
right and to see where that thing is
going and i guess like i said the
excitement is for me particularly has
been with the seasonal model is what
where is it going to go next what what
is the next
major story beat and um yeah i think
it's just one of those things that you
know we're excited with everything you
guys are doing i cannot wait to see
where the story goes to be honest that
is literally
to be like i tell people all the time
that don't play destiny you know destiny
is in its best place narratively right
now if you care about story if you care
about character and development and
where this thing is going crow we need
to hurry you up into the hunter yeah oh
we need to hurry you up crow but he's
gotta earn it he's gotta earn it
i will say i am very excited to see what
you do with the future but also
specifically this season i know kyle's
coming and that relationship because you
gave us some threads with duality
i love the the relationship there as far
as the callus
gaul even say hey i spared your hand if
it wasn't for your daughter like i love
the these type of interactive band and
the thing i want to give you guys credit
while here is one of my major p's and he
knows this is that
having the multiple characters interact
with each other multiple voice actors
that to me made the world seem more
alive you know when i would do some of
the battleground missions salad and
we'll be talking and osiris will be like
that now it feels like this world you
created so salute to the team and kudos
on that because i just feel that
narratively you guys really in the best
place and to see the progression of this
game on that level has been good
yeah good
good i was just gonna say quick before
you go because i know we're running out
of time uh favorite season that your
team worked on and favorite season that
vanguard omega worked on
good one
um
let me see uh i mean 30th was a blast
there yeah
because it wasn't like a normal season
we got to just be wacky and weird and
the team really i think all the teams
like everyone's
weapons narrative like everybody
like activity designers they all brought
their a game was incredible um
and from omega like
um
i
i still feel like chosen was really good
and i know that season uh
season
15 with the welcome was amazing and i'm
really excited about
the next few ones that they're working
on
two
um like it's that's another thing that's
really interesting about like working on
the seasons is like we only work on half
over there and i don't work on the
annual stuff so our whole team like we
get to be just like y'all we get to be
fans when the other releases are
dropping so like when season 18 comes
out i'm gonna be right there like ready
to play it i barely know anything it's
awesome
cool eat real quickly are you going to
ask the raid question favorite rate you
know we always do that yeah i guess that
may be that's a fun way to end it um but
i just wanted to say first off i want to
say thank you for coming on the show
because i know we are running low on
time but it was an absolute pleasure
having you but as we always have a
little bit of contention here and you've
been at destiny and bungie in the mix
for a long time as a player
top three raids can you rank can you
rank three
i rank three for a full franchise
doesn't matter d1 or d2
we need to know my personal story
yeah this is your personal three your
person we'll judge you accordingly as a
player this is dev is off the table
right now
can i throw uh dungeons in there too and
just mix three at the top why not
i guess so he kind of cheating though
because he didn't uh i mean we could be
it's tough we just did it like
vlog is like probably just my all-time
favorite just because like the
experiences that i had and like
it's more about the friends like i used
to play with pope bear
and a lot of other people in the
community
and then like i think for me it was more
all the raids are amazing but it's more
about the people and the time
and like i played a ton of ball to glass
and crota's end
and um king's fall with those friends
those i wouldn't say those are all my
favorite uh but like vlog is in my top
three for sure um i think wrath is up up
there
rather so much fun
siege engine man c
yeah and i think he's well would
probably be three just for the scale of
it but it was it was really hard i
remember lots of like lfg groups
breaking apart it in that last fight
it was real really hard but it was
really good and and also that the t-rex
armor was just oh yeah
that was cool
yeah that's solid let's see he's got all
those colors we've got we got he's got
his you know his kig's fault
basically
it's basically my exact order so yeah
the only one i would say in contention
probably would be last wish could sneak
in the mix with those three but those
three are strong super strong i like it
i'm convinced
well from the inspiration from getting
to know you a little bit from kind of
the questions that i sent you and seeing
where a lot of your even inspiration is
even come from you know you say mario or
zelda and this gets pulled from here and
the other stuff i know i'm very excited
for what's to come in the future and all
i can say is when we see on twitter that
you guys scream bungie
all the time
that actually makes it really fun to
follow a lot of you guys because you all
being extremely excited to work for the
company that you work for being excited
for the future and that's like code word
of i just saw this amazing thing and i
can't say anything about it except
scream the word bungie
and yeah
yeah whatever that means
oh okay that's the code that's the next
one that you can disclose your agreement
yeah that's that's the one that you get
to scream out next time it's ada
bungie
um i just i think i'll say on behalf of
everybody it's like the stories that you
guys have been telling especially in the
past couple years i even mentioned at
one point i was like hey can we get like
an animated and then he's like i don't
know what to call them the inkblot
animated cut scenes you know like the
one i just got with zavala
what do you guys call what you call
those guys
we call them like uh i guess either
concept art cutscenes or uh digital art
cinematics gotcha uh yeah yeah yeah the
stories the seasons um
you guys are in a place that is i feel
running on on just
full steam ahead and i think a lot of us
can easily say that we're very excited
to see where we're going because after
witch queen risen now haunted hitting
deep with the story cuts and everybody's
crying on twitter i don't know what
you're gonna do to us next but i'm not
sure the emotions can go for it but i
will say lightfall is
i don't know what you're going to do to
us but i think we're all very excited so
as i know we are kind of coming up on
time with you i wanted to give you a
chance to step away but before you go um
do you have any words for anybody who
listens to this or just where to find
you or just you know if you want to drop
the giant bomb of what you're working on
i know you can't do that
no i mean first of all i want to say
like i'm out here representing like
hundreds of people that work on
destiny uh bungie on destiny and like
i'm really like i'm like super fortunate
to be here and be able to represent the
team but like there's there's so many
talented people that go into everything
you get to play in destiny and i'm
actually you know i'm so excited that
you all three of you are so passionate
and excited about where we're going and
like we're excited too obviously and
about the next few years but like i know
there's things too that there's
criticisms of the game too i don't want
to like pray that everything's perfect
in destiny keep the feedback coming like
we appreciate the community he's amazing
like we're so lucky um like i'm i'm on
twitter if you want to find me it's time
for the web but i mostly just post [ __ ]
posts and memes and
and and other stuff don't expect any
news there i'm definitely going to defer
to our our community and player support
teams um
but yeah it was thank you so much for
having me and uh i i'm gonna be
listening uh to you guys and then your
next few podcasts here for sure
appreciate your absolute pleasure man
love what shout out to you the entire
team obviously we know it's a collective
effort what you guys are doing it's just
fun to see the journey of this game
obviously you know we have we're going
to give you guys credit and we will
criticize when need be of course you
know but we love the transparency and
the fact that you know i always feel
like it's okay to be critical as long as
you're respectful and you have that
discourse and that's the main thing and
i i i want people to be clear there's a
correct way to do it and we really
appreciate the time you and the team
kind of gave us just to dig deeper into
holla behind the
and thank you travis lord cognito and
abantas for having me thank you so much
uh i know like you've taken time for
your time out too to spend some time
with this summer some some game design
guy with me
uh it's it's a lot of fun we don't get
to directly interact with community like
this all the time so that's something
we're celebrating it was absolutely our
pleasure and please pass along our
thanks for for one your time to your
family of course and place our thanks to
or send our thanks to the entire teams
everybody over there at the studio is
absolutely crushing it we can't wait to
see what's next and biggest thing
everybody criticism is real just keep it
reasonable
exactly
nothing's perfect we're always trying to
get better but yeah we're we're very
thankful that you were able to come on
and join us
yeah next we need to talk to vanguard
omega that's our next uh next season
right yeah
tap the other shoulder right yeah for
sure all right cool all right awesome
i'm going to uh put a little pause here
in the episode so we will be right back
for those of you that are live so hang
tight and
uh we will be back
go for it go for it
all right i think
is mostly good
what's up everybody we should be back
you should be able to hear us and i know
we had a little break in the episode
there but we had to uh
make sure and let tom get out so um
thank you guys all for being here for us
for the show if you guys are enjoying it
please make sure you drop some likes on
the show uh thank you guys chat for
being
very nice and reasonable too um good to
see chat playing clean and nice with
something like this we want to make sure
we can maybe try and do something like
that again in the future
um
yeah so part two of the episode is now
here uh tom has taken off to his evening
he's got life and stuff to get to so we
were able to still a little bit of his
time so we thank you um
before we go touch on that one though we
all just got back from gcx
yeah and somehow we dodged
did the dodgeball with the virus um but
it does seem like it got a few people so
sorry i got food poisoning oh really
yeah yeah so here's the thing uh teddy
got kovit and he was my roommate
right that thing but my girlfriend and i
who were in the same room as him did not
get coveted but teddy and i both also
got food poisoning because florida's a
hellscape so
teddy got home with
covet and food poisoning
yeah we made the mistake of trying to
eat pizza in florida which is just uh
like why would you ever attract that
you know what's funny is i was standing
in line and i said i said teddy you said
teddy said i'm still dying
yeah dude he is for sure teddy like
literally teddy was like i'm gonna get
pizza and i looked at the pizza i went
over the line with them i was like dude
that does not look edible i'm gonna sit
this one out and he was like fine i'm
gonna get a pizza by myself and he got
it by himself i got a different you know
i got a sandwich or whatever but then we
get back up to the hotel room and i'm
like you know what this pizza looks so
terrible i have to try it just out of
morbid curiosity and i tried one slice
and i got food poisoning for like two
days it was brutal anyway uh i'm never
going to florida again that state can
burn so if you guys didn't meet travis
on this trip it ain't going to happen it
is going to happen
but travis that may have been a one-time
thing yeah i would say that it was it
was good
to alex kilgore's point in the comments
i'm used to my uh my kale pizza here in
san francisco yeah cauliflower crust
okay flower crust
olive oil all that yeah dude literally
teddy looked at the pizza and he was
like
this looks really undercooked and then
he ate it anyway
that is a classic teddy invitation that
was classic the pause the the eye was
really
yeah
i got really good at my teddy
impressions spending that time
yo shout out to my first one shout out
to y'all it was so good to see y'all you
know
travis yo you know what's funny e
dealing with travis on the podcast right
but in the flesh it is extra like it is
it is everything and more
live it is a live show every time i'm
with this [ __ ] i just
don't even have a you can't wrap your
head around what is travis
in real life you get the podcast version
he tries not to get my channel
demonetized but yeah he's light you
don't
like no the last word what this man does
for one this intelligent human because i
know he's not dumb
wears suits in florida and complains
about it being hot that's your own damn
fault
it's the only clothes he wears i know
because i went into his room and he's
like look at the clothes i brought dress
shirts dress pants suits
that was all that was in his closet i'm
pretty sure at that point his suitcase
was empty so
but he does have the inside lapel not
even not the lapel the inside of the
coat it's embroidered with thai guy
travis that is for real i have seen it
multiple times now
absolutely
hilarious
we got a chance to build it it's oh
teddy said i can convert me sleep to the
suit i'm done two jammers he's not lying
suit jammers salute bro they're like it
was funny i gotta shout out some people
oh again shout out to the whole shout
out to the the destiny bestie we finally
made that happen with everybody got a
chance to meet dj oros his fam the whole
the whole crew you know said i'll be
that pulled up alex back for dead um my
boy tom i was gonna say everyone since
you mentioned uh dj
yeah so don't worry
okay so this is a hilarious thing that
happened i blame cog for this completely
so
cog tells me dj oros is getting ready to
you know getting ready for covet okay
and he's like okay and dj's like all
right well i may not be in the best
shape and you know none of us were it's
like working on it for next year but
he's like hey i'm gonna have the best
cavs and cat cogs like whoa whoa
slow down boy
yeah so like yeah i was like so cog is
like building me up and i'm just like
i have no idea what this dude's calves
look like but all of a sudden i have
entered in a calf off before i even show
up at gcx
finally
well no finally he like we record
episode 200 which i promise you is
getting out there but due to some
editing and stuff that i've got to do
it's just going to take me a little
while and i've been trying to catch up
on content so it'll happen you'll just
see it dropped
he just saved me ak [ __ ] messed it up
the recording
i've gotta i've just gotta do some
editing it'll happen um hopefully cross
your fingers there that episode was a
nightmare don't post that's mine
shout out to charcoal yeah yeah yeah
alex that was there shout out everybody
i was patient with my foolishness thank
you uh continue continue so we get all
of 200 recorded friday night and we're
waiting for all these people whose
flights are getting delayed because
everybody like physics amazed they got
there at like
12 o'clock midnight one o'clock or
whatever but we're finally waiting and
then you tell me it's like hey dj orris
is coming so finally he gets in there
he comes into the bar and i was like hey
how's the hockey treat knows the first
thing i said jimmy's are you seriously
that's what you're going to say to me so
that was hilarious then we do this
little calf off
you you tell me all right
i was like you judged and you're like
okay it was good this is but you tell
work out here this is one of the most
intense matchups i was looking forward
to you know we had to see you know the
reigning champion
from texas you know with cavs the sounds
of cows we don't call him cats what he
bonds his ass you know what i mean and
then the up-and-comer you know what i'm
saying and i know dj orris is outside
i've been in conventions with him one of
the most defined cavs i've seen so i was
like yo it might be close now initially
i said i still got faith in my boy he
should pull it off but it was closer
than i thought it was close to that
though i get cuz he's like but but he
ain't like the whole this man is upset
that he lost the calf off he's like but
but mine's more defined than his i'm
like bro it's just you lost it's cool
but you know you can have that moral
victory for yourself and that's cool
let's go get the drinks and the whole
trip this man is having his wife take
pictures of his cat from different
angles it's like you see you see
this is why he got i'm like yo this is
hilarious but we had so much fun this
trip the foolishness and then oh shout
out to backfield oh no and then so
what i wanted to wrap up with that was
uh my wife probably had one of the
better jokes of all afterwards was
finally like just let them know when you
get home you're going to start in only
cavs
[Laughter]
and that's going to be you know some
people i hear people have like foot
fetishes so maybe somebody out there has
a calf fetish outside of like lily from
how i met your mother that's the only
one i know of but i thought that was
hilarious and apparently
my ass is a shock absorber yes and
travis has to tell you travis has to
tell the story because all i knew is i'm
sitting there i was like i got to meet
last lady legend previous guest on the
podcast um really cool to chat i'm
literally middle of discussion with her
and then travis
how does that i don't even know the
build up to this thing the build up is
that i was talking to somebody and i
noticed that ibontis was standing in the
distance and he's super engrossed in a
conversation with lady legend who's been
a
friend of the show lady legend if you're
here
and uh i decided that i was going to
slap his butt to say
hello to him that morning that was my my
how you doing uh thing so i get behind
him and i turn to all the people behind
me because everybody sees i'm about to
do it and he's completely oblivious so
i'm like all right i'm gonna i'm gonna
make a show out of this so i did this
whole thing like i'm just like warming
up my hands i went in with like a
running start swung my arm as far back
as i could and hit him and i've done
this many times and you know to other
other friends of mine and usually you
hit them and it's just like this big
cracking noise and then they're like oh
you know like like jumping around
no no noise came out of e at the moment
impact it was like punching a memory
foam mattress it was unbelievable it 100
absorbed the blow
and my it like i like hit his butt and
it like fought back it like sent like a
like a
shock wave through my arm and i was like
oh my god that like hurt a lot
i must have been leaning on that cheek
or something who knows it was
unbelievable and everyone who was
watching me was like
did he miss did he miss it there was no
noise and he didn't react at all he kind
of just turned around and was like
is there a fly around here what happened
dude it was it was like i tapped him on
the shoulder it was unbelievable so
not only does he win the cavs contest
but that buttocks man
it is uh
major cheeky
cheeks man those cheeks
he's the master cheese master cheeks
he is master cheeks
but we all went to dinner and then
you're telling this
half of the restaurant could probably
hear this story but my choice is that
quiet y'all no by the way travis doesn't
have an inside voice he has the opposite
of a library voice it's like normally
yeah his normal is like everybody's like
hey you're gonna have a conversation
with somebody that's like five he starts
at eight
he begins all conversations at eight and
then it goes up maybe to 11 who knows
but my wife
well she just was dying she loved that
story she was just
she was laughing so so she knows
she knows the cheek qualities she knows
about it
all i can say to everybody out there
don't skip playing day there's a reason
for that
man the man's bedroom man but i didn't
want to shout out like i said back for
dead that pulled up had so much fun
meeting him and his wife the whole team
like i said on my boy ty
it's co so cool to meet him in person
long neck was in the building a lot of
great content i finally got to get a
chance to meet cross
glad was there of course be grey in the
buildings
that's so nice seriously be great for
one smile that's like you look at it and
he smiles and you're just like yep i'm
happy now he's cool but yeah like nice
dude like
uh
i i mean there are there were some it
was
so we were talking to tom before the
show
and i mentioned to him like
you know i heard and we heard from the
floor people the bungie kind of had to
commit a year ago middle of 2021
nobody's going to commit to do anything
then so it makes sense that they weren't
there
but the key is
like we missed them being there but even
though they weren't there it did feel a
little bit more chill so when you bumped
into somebody you actually got a chance
to talk to people um it had this it had
a different vibe on the floor was like
you have a conversation it's like while
you know it's kind of a building year
for the conference i got a chance to
talk to a ton of people just very
casually which was really really cool um
met so many people already got multiple
guests that i'm gonna work on getting on
here um
yeah like there's
if you guys don't know him
j
o overrated i think that's his twitter
but it's
his name's joey um i know he and follow
up play a decent amount and i didn't
know this because i watched followed a
good amount but i hadn't watched him but
i knew they played together and stuff
like that and i met him and i'm sitting
there going and i tried really hard not
to say it but i was like has anybody
told you you kind of look like fallout
and he's like
dude
every day like he hears that all the
time and he has like kind of a mustache
going on but he's actually trying to
like curl the corners on it and stuff um
so like chatter with him he's gonna be
hilarious i know uh big daddy teage has
i got a chance to talk to
life is still a legend oh no question
oh no
this this is what i do
you know i got that moment and you're
like yo i i can't i i i'm somewhere now
i'm going places
so i'm sitting there and it was like you
you landed what was it wednesday i came
in wednesday night or thursday morning
yeah i was thursday so thursday whatever
whatever so one of my friends shout out
to dreadpool wanted to shout out
dreadpool who's in the state of florida
he's like hey you guys going to be there
i want to meet you i'm like cool i'll
come down for my roommate in the lobby
shout out to the leviathan lobby the
costello the most glorious outstanding
this place is amazing but anyway so come
down here
it's opulent so i come down there boom
talking to my boy dreadful whatever so
in the distance you know you could tell
someone's like waiting to talk to you
like in the distance so i'm like alright
whatever
if i don't turn around
and it is my name is wife and he said
it's so cool he was like i was speaking
to hebanthus and i was like where's lord
there's like his lord here and i was
like he's like i have to talk to him and
i saw that had to be you so i had to
make sure we had our conversation i was
like my man like that made my whole trip
just that body he was waiting to talk to
me i was like this is cool i made it i i
could die now it was all good we just
talked and talked about law and
everything that he's doing it was so
good to see him and catch up shout out
to my name is bob i had to tell the bye
story because brother you made my trip
as soon as i started so absolutely
it's like i first bumped it i heard him
and d flawless who d flawless ultra nice
dude he was he was everywhere he didn't
say no to anything we got him on 200
that's why i do want to try and edit it
and get it up there um
but dude was just everywhere uh doing
all this yeah he was everywhere yeah i
feel like i hung out with d flawless
that whole
time like he was just he was just with
me the whole time yeah every place that
was probably flaws was there
yep thanks um
but yeah i was like so and then i heard
him and bye for sitting down having
lunch and i was like
life is here like on thursday when next
nobody's here it's like i want to go but
then i see literally the two of them
having lunch and i was like hey just
want to stop by and say hey
of course he would like let his food get
cold if you sat there and talked to him
long enough so i had to bail on that one
a little bit but i got a chance to stop
by the booth i was there sunday morning
i went in and i got like third in line
waiting for him to get to his booth and
i got a chance to talk to him and
between him
i know was there almost nearly the whole
time talking to everybody going through
the lines and there's
you could always imagine like meeting a
celebrity or something like that it's
like and then destiny celebrities you
know it's all relative but
being million subscribers and basically
as big as they are him and then datto
and trap and danielle both of them
their lines were long but the reason
they were long for one people probably
rotated through but they had a full
conversation with every single person
they were on their feet they were
killing them if you saw danielle's
twitter she's like i'm gonna be a little
late i'm not sick i'm just old it's
gonna take the feet a little while i saw
them go barefoot
a lot of those people just stand there
to meet people and say hello and
especially those two you know it's just
it's a full conversation every time
because you watch the person and a
couple people in front of you go so i
just wanted to shout out those legends
because they truly went the whole
weekend and i can honestly tell you most
gamers are probably half introverts if
not more
most people are probably leaning
introverts so people of that you know
personality
meeting people constantly you want to
talk about people that are just drained
after two days there are some people who
really thrive on social and there are
people who are somewhere in the middle
and there's people it's like social
interaction is draining
i don't know where some of them fall but
i can tell you it's like at the end of
it they were everybody's wiped because
they put in their time i just wanted to
shout those out because so many people
but yeah cb gray was there glad was
there
um i mean you got to see good amount of
g1 advanced gg they held down the middle
of the party shout out to advanced
fusion we had to power
[Laughter]
all good um
but yeah we actually got to see there
was a 1v1 battle for g1 they had some
1v1 that was actually pretty cool to
watch uh some definitely legit players
in there
uh bumped into just so many people but i
just had fun
it was a lighter show but i had fun
talking to so many people
yes uh yeah and astrocrash was the same
way he was having he was having some
good conversations bumped into him just
honestly ultra nice guy all those guys
were yes shout out to a maze shout out
to you amazing oh my god
yeah i think of them all amazing yeah he
was there too ill physics
oh
physics is also super nice yeah
so yeah it's just you keep bumping into
somebody else and you it's like and you
meet multiple creators met and just it
didn't stop and that was kind of the fun
part of the weekend was bumping into
another person getting to know him a
little bit chatting but it was like
honestly just hanging out with you guys
was a blast that was
that was probably the most fun just
that's the only reason i went i don't
really know any content creators i don't
talk to them i'm kind of on the other
side of it because you guys are actually
content creators and i'm
press
but uh you're making you make a butt ton
of content
but i'm not i'm not a content creator
come on i just sit here and talk to you
guys and then i write reviews so uh but
yeah they you know the cool part for me
was meeting the people who watched this
show i met some people that watched the
other show i'm on bitcast i met lots of
people who recognized me from fire team
chat and didn't know i was doing this
show so it was cool to be like yo you
should listen the last word
uh so that was cool and then uh just
meeting you guys by the way i just gotta
say this if anybody has not met if
anybody has not met ibontis incognito in
person these dudes
look way different in person than they
do on camera on camera we look like
peers
in in person
i look like their kid they are
huge they are huge they've got big
square bodies and all of their parts are
just big and round just just big round
torsos big round arms big round wait are
you calling me
no just like you guys are barrel chested
monsters you're just big you're big and
so my they've got these gears of war
model characters as they're as the thing
so they are no longer ibontis incognito
to me to me they are marcus phoenix and
the coltrane and they always will be
marcus and cole
is what i'm going to call these two
forever because they just were they just
walking around together was so bro was
so bro
just walking around it was crazy i was
like these guys are huge they'd be like
all right travis let me give you a hug
say goodbye and i'm just like
jesus dude travis is the guy like when
you give him a hug you gotta be gentle
as you feel like
you feel like you're gonna give him like
a chiropractic session with like a hug
just like snap his back a little bit
there it was unbelievable it's like it's
like hugging a sumo wrestler these guys
are just giant and so anyway
the camera is deceptive you say the
camera adds 10 pounds on them it removes
50 pounds of muscle is what it does
they're huge they're huge dudes he kept
saying that he's like bro he's like you
are way both of y'all way bigger person
and they're tall they're tall and big
it's yeah just
nuts that is that is one of those things
that you never know when you watch
anybody streaming video content create
or whatever you never quite know how
tall people are you can get a gauge of
like
apparently it's hard to gauge okay ek is
huge
oh ek is like six five absolutely yeah
yeah ek is six five um one other guy was
like six seven but i mean uh cb gray i
think he's like six one six two i mean
he's lean but
you also meet some on the other side and
you're like hey you're short and it's
like you see them kind of both sides
because you never know you just get to
see usually about this much of the
person
that's true and camera's always
deceiving you'd be like hey
but oh hold on you know what i wasn't
nobody was surprised by what i looked
like everyone saw me and they were like
yep he's that size he's that skinny like
yep travis
travis is a pocket human that's that's
what he little fighter
everybody i got a shout out in the chat
right now because this is this is a
classic story warren d said oh yeah it
was so fun crabbing in the back seat of
a rental car with clemson downdu and
cognito on the way back for the advanced
gg event shout out to them shout out to
dj or something like driving us all back
it's like a cloud car in the back oh my
god yeah it's like four it's like the
gears of war guys trying to drive a mini
cooper or something i couldn't hear you
guys shout out to warren d shout out to
clemson great guys they i felt like
everywhere we were where they were there
too which was kind of funny so salute to
them that was hilarious that that visual
no doubt
no that was fun and that's the thing
about the the leviathan i actually told
people that they kind of were like you
know that actually makes sense because
rosen shingle creek as a resort has like
1500 rooms which is no small feat in and
of itself three pools full golf course
behind it it's on this like acreage that
they bought but they were the smart
person because in florida in the summer
or whatever weather you're going to have
you are air conditioned from your room
all the way to the conference center to
the restaurants and the bars that are in
between them and everything um
and you never have to go outside because
i know tampa fairgrounds when we sweat
all of everything that we have on our
body off like yeah we're just like
trying to get in line i almost went to
curse you out you made us cross the
street to the burger spot i was like
that that short distance i was almost
drooling oh dude yeah it's it's i'm
walking my dogs right now in 80 degrees
i'm just like oh so no it's
uh but that place truly is unique and
they got the big piece of the conference
hall this time i just can't wait for
next year uh it's going to be august 4th
and 5th next year so you got like 14
months to plan for it yes um away from
e3 please
yeah it's like that's actually pretty
good spacing for any of your guys
coverage stuff you should be completely
safe there gamescom you guys said is
like later so that shouldn't be as much
of an issue either but i don't know if
we'll get travis back but cog and i know
we'll we'll be there yeah
august i could do august yeah but it was
tough because to travis defense you know
he's got to do coverage we had the the
xbox but that's the conference that
weekend there was a lot going on so you
know i'm just happy you know i'm saying
even if like i said traffic can't make
it again we've all got to meet and hang
out and chill like a whole weekend do
everything together eat dinner chill bug
out jokes speaking of eating y'all suck
[Laughter]
and by the way i eat sauce i eat
seasoned food i don't eat bland boiled
crap
wow thanks guys i'll say that i'll say
this much florida is perfect for
imontos's flavor palette let me just say
that much yes
shout out to him for um putting some
axles
he did put sauce on one of his spoons on
some of the burrito it was
it was a um
enchilada a safe move
very safe very simple but
it was big we all got more than i
expected we all stopped the whole table
got quiet it just looked it was like
what does he do is he actually i put
sauce
on my enchiladas yeah what there was
like a glaze on a burger and i ate that
i had a cheeseburger over the weekend
and blew my blue people's minds like
yeah that was that was the first night
of dinner when there was a big enough
group of us there
wallace was there too i swear he was
everywhere um
yeah yeah that that definitely was half
the evening of what's going to be on
your food
oh travis you would be proud um before
we left on monday because we stayed
there an extra day and most people were
trying to fly back
my wife and i hung outside
shout out to lupo and his wife by the
way because they were out at the pool i
didn't want to bother him because they
were just hanging out with a couple
friends um
he and his wife are adorable and cute as
well so that's always nice to see a
couple like that that also seem like
they have some fun but we are grabbing
food at the bar
bartender comes out and chatting with
him for a little bit he grabs this like
little pedialyte packet
because he was like trying to get like
you know just like throw something in
his water or whatever and travis to no
surprise guess what
i literally while he was at the bar he
bought some focus on his phone
he was moving my powder because i had i
had the hydra i had the hydration in my
bag i was like dude just try it i
literally gave him the tub he's like
what i was like just just try it he
threw it in the water and he was like
this is good and he's like how do i
order he literally ordered in front of
me and i got home the next day and
checked the website sure enough like
literally ordered it in front of me and
i was just like all right travis would
be proud living up to it over here there
you go moving that way there you go yeah
so did he use did he use your code yes
he did
oh wow struck another blow against the
lords of gaming and their 30 percent off
code yeah
look man we completely how we go well
you're losing you're losing okay he's
out here pushing he's pushing powder on
the streets okay you're just
you're just tweeting codes you're just
tweeting
yeah
i'm out here knocking on doors yeah he's
knocking on doors standing on street
corners
seafood is so good around the gulf get
your life together traffic what you get
your life together yeah my life's pretty
together and it's together enough to
never go back to florida
no to be fair to be fair mri gamer we're
in orlando okay orlando is
being on the pale even for florida it's
not it's not great so that you know i
i've been to miami there's some good
food in miami this was not miami this
was orlando
he would get a chance check discord sir
um but other than that yeah man i i
really enjoyed that and then we really
give teddy enough love though trav teddy
it was cool to hang out with teddy ted
man he was it was just fun he was still
he was dope
and one of the best uh like he was in
rare form with his audio work and stuff
like that so salute to him on that that
was cool i got a chance to hang out
teddy actually went to a party with me
so that was actually pretty interesting
i know because his flight got cancelled
and so he ended up going to the party
with you guys and i i think that's where
he got covered because i didn't get it
and he did so he was like not worth it
not worth going to an extra party
getting ls6 to be honest i was nervous i
did get it too because that last day i
missed when you left because i think i
was just recording all day you were you
were i was completely locked out of
social media but um when the day be when
his flight got delayed cancelled and
then he's leaving on my day and then um
we would we like hung out that whole
night then went uber together to the
airport so i'm like oh i have my mind
i'm like oh i got it but i was like
listen for teddy he's perfect
i was like teddy's wherever he gave me
the big heart i was like i'll take that
i was shocked i thought for sure but
yeah so it is what it is but like i said
i had a great time y'all with everybody
that pulled me yeah you know what i'm
saying no doubt cool
yeah man so we got that and i know he's
working behind the scene um did you get
a chance to reach this 12 track i did
yeah and i'll just say uh before we go
into the twap since we we were we were
blessed to have tom on today yeah i just
want to say like
that's super awesome and also by the way
is not a common thing in the games
industry so you know say what you will
about bungie and you know some of their
uh content that you don't like or you
know their their business practices if
you don't like the content fault but it
is a super rarefied thing for
a a a developer to just say yeah go and
talk to three fans of the game that run
a weekly youtube show and just talk to
them about what you do and game design
and and do that for 30 minutes like that
is
that is dope that is super cool and it's
why
i think people have such a close
relationship with destiny because they
feel like they're part of the community
and they're part of something that is
unique and incredible and it's also why
bungie gets so much praise rightfully so
for its community management it's
community management is
second to none so so good so
yeah it's awesome man and i just i want
to give the shout out to
bunji for letting tom do that and come
on our show and talk to
us three nerds and and also shout out to
shout out to ibontis for coordinating
and making that happen
always pushing to make sure we get
guests every week so yeah shout out to e
man you know i i want to give him his
flowers live too because obviously you
know before you know you came on travis
it was being him and i had more of a
responsibility than my responsibilities
picked up and i just couldn't do as much
but you know he has really put his
fingerprint on the show and it makes
life easier for us so salute to you you
know for making that happen this is
tremendous like travis you're absolutely
100 right as far as the bungee thing i'm
super proud because at the end of the
day you know that's a big deal you know
to trust this platform to come on
campfire and to know you know nothing
crazy is going to happen but at the same
time you know to say hey these guys are
worth our time you know and we
definitely shout out to the whole team
that is rare and we we truly truly do
appreciate that so salute the e and
bungie at the same time that's right
uh i mean that's yeah thank you guys
both um i mean happy to have all of you
guys show up live in chat keeping us
going all the views all the listens
everywhere you guys find this podcast
believe me we appreciate every time you
guys i'm on the show say hello you're
live in chat you listen just see the
numbers and everything for all of you
guys listening to us you helped make it
happen um and getting some
someone like tom to join us on the show
was
something we've both wanted i know cog
and then i know travis you've
interviewed people but for
me and especially on my scale it's
something
that's literally one of my first you
know dev interviews i know cogs had a
ton of those on iron lord's podcast but
i mean it's a show about destiny we
actually get one of the developers on
there and
the fact that you know you guys were
very cool in chat everything and
everything went well it's just like i
mean yeah thank you guys for all of that
and
just doing my best over here that's all
i'm trying to do everybody doing today
and i would be remiss if we didn't shout
out skye lewin who we did have oh
absolutely yeah audio to give that's
everything
and composer yeah to give them their
flowers on music because you know i'll
be on the front line for that
they'll die on that sword oh yeah i
still think they should nominate every
year they should be in the running for
these soundtracks that they do so salute
to them as well um shout out to mri
gamer got you with the fight out of
super chat also great get with the
bungee dev ibantas and much success to
all the guys
i appreciate the double super chats uh
big time great
um before we get to the tribe did you
guys play the story this week
yeah yeah i did oh i know my boy zavala
who's another bungee person i've
interviewed if you consider him a bungie
person yeah you got to talk remember
that if we could go
in here i'm going to have to i'm going
to have trouble maintaining it all we
got to do is wait for him this is how
fire team chat got him
just got to wait for him to start making
the uh the press tour for whatever show
or movie he's promoting because that was
uh bosch but whatever that amazon show
is
he was promoting like a bosch the new
season of that and then he was like yeah
taking press requests and we were like
let's let's get him on so
uh yeah just wait for him to be on the
show or something you probably got him
okay
probably dope
but anyway he's the subject of this
week's story yeah
what do you guys think
spoilers by the way spoiler if you
haven't played it spoilers played this
week's episode the zavala part 2
situation
i love that idea for episode 200 the
last word
a lost word
i like that because that should never
see the light of day
i'm going to have to listen to that
whole thing before it goes out because
guess look worst case scenario
that is not episode 200 and this episode
is yeah
yeah worst case scenario
there are worse things we'll see we'll
see yeah audio only may definitely
happen
we got that option
probably only you'll thank me later
thank you lately okay shout out to you
shout out to teddy for making uh
checking out the audio yeah we got phase
two of zavala
dealing with everything we got last week
and i'm kind of getting this
first week of
npc's
grief shame you know those two
were
those hit pretty hard
you see you know hearing crow just like
actually like screaming aldrin the first
time he went through and then we got our
eyes completely opened about zavala and
safi is that her name
yeah yeah
and last week it was getting to see
he nearly gave it all up and we got to
see him completely
go through all of that and then with
what he lost
and then finally kind of come back and
how he was with shax and everything all
together it's been
i feel like the build up of the first
week
i don't know if they almost set the bar
so high
that the second week
doesn't quite hit it like the resolution
for crow
almost felt like it came a little easy
and i don't mean that in a bad way but
does that make i'm trying to figure out
how to say that words
like zavala like people are crying on
twitter last week when zavala gets it
and then this week you don't see as much
of the reaction because it's the
resolution it's not it's like up and
down it's like a very quick roller
coaster it's not the loops and twists
and anything in between
well i also think that they they kind of
dropped most of their content that first
week because we got a whole unique uh
cut scene that explained the backstory
that up until that point had been
exclusively told in the extended lore
never never really truly canonized in
um destiny proper and so
i i do think they it seems like they put
more work in the setup and then the the
resolution kind of feels inevitable but
yeah i
with the crow one i feel like hit harder
for me because the crow resolution had
been
set up for a long time yes i agree
zavala kind of felt like it came out of
nowhere to me like it was like oh wow i
didn't know any of this about zavala
cool and then all right well it's
already resolved whereas crow we we knew
he was struggling with that for a long
time and so it felt they hit a little
differently for me
yeah no he i i hate you on um
good point with crow because obviously
we the history that's been going on
longer
with
for me zavala's initial was strong
because
i loved this storyboard set up i loved
seeing the relationship you know behind
the wall so to speak with saladin and
him kind of breaking away to do this
relationship kind of thing knowing about
the sun hakeem i you know all that stuff
was interesting to me but i'm with you
travis like
the resolution may have been a little
too quick for my tastes you know what
i'm saying but i thought overall the
story what the message that was conveyed
i was cool with it i just felt like the
resolution came a little quick and maybe
it's because
maybe it's the cadence is back to back
and maybe that's what it is and i feel
like i'm getting it too fast it's just a
little bit a little bit i i do feel but
i am i will say this i am
looking forward to what's gonna happen
with kyle like to me
because the end of this was interesting
to the way she was talking to him you
know to absolve his stuff and you know
you've been through the mental thing but
i feel like she's holding on to
something i'm very curious to see
narratively where they go with her like
we was telling tom when tom was here but
um yeah i get what you're saying i i i
think what you're saying there is some
validity there with the quickness of the
resolution of the sever you know and i
don't know if maybe we just got it too
fast and maybe it should have been
another week between with something else
i don't know
yeah it's it's it's not like i'm saying
the storytelling is bad because they're
getting so kind of a lot of
you know what's going on inside of
crow's head it's a really cool way to
visualize it as we discussed before
zavala we actually get to see his
backstory in him having to face his
painful demon that he's been
basically suppressing for a very long
period of time
and then it's like it's cool to see that
and again they do have to have this
cadence of here's the major issue and
then it has to be some kind of
resolution to take that nightmare and
turn it into a memory that's going to be
able to be used by eris my curiosity is
going to be tidal
title and callous i think has potential
to
be big because we have an odd number of
weeks we have three we have two that you
expect if you get the same cadence and
maybe it's just the three memories and
then you get the clean separation
but
is that how it's going to be
or will it be keital and gaul oh i think
it's kind of a goal
that's true
some demon she has with gaul because we
saw gaul's
nightmare i think she was his
let's get girlfriend
let's get it like that that was fire i
like that
because he was selected he was he was
the
you know the story with red one and i
gotta remember it you know he was the
runt that kind of worked his way up the
ladder then became like the you know the
most dominant glad you know of all that
that he was selected by what's your man
i like the the other the other
cabal that was like he that he was
making all the protege right
i forget his name now but the whole
thing was
kind of orchestrated like i said the me
i love that the midnight coup i love
perfect weapon name you know saying like
buy all of them to get kallus out of
there so kaido's role in that and the
relationship what
what does she have guilt for or what
what's because it's it's
it's shame for crow
grief for savala do we know what the
third name is the third you know
thirstiness
yes
i'm glad you have yeah
is she thirsty for zavala oh
thirstiness guys
her tusks aren't the only thing that's
horny okay oh my god and all i'm saying
is i'm glad this part of the episode is
going to get beeped out
yo she be shooting her shot was wild
like everything even it's a it's an
interesting like love slash respect
between her and zavala that's what i'm
saying there's like inside it bro i
think she wants a drink of the blue milk
that's right
she ready to be woke
she up she wants to wake up with the
awoken i think that's what she wants to
do
yeah for sure and that's dude it's even
it's even movement
it's even more obvious in the lore
snippets yeah you guys read those oh she
is extra extra for sure dude what she's
dropping mad hints bad yeah
you know he act like he don't hear it he
knows it he knows for sure
don't have a word for surrender or
subtlety with with their uh with their
advances or straight business but like
fairness to zavala like he's been
repressing so much
do you ever feel like if he can finally
get some type of peace and closure and
move forward from
safy
that he can
i don't know how that relationship would
work though that's so weird she's like
nine foot six or whatever or however
tall he is
remember when you hugged me
[Laughter]
that's the kind of it's gonna be
gears of war
it is cool though and this is again why
again like for tom coming on it's like
he said it too he even mentioned about
season 10 like the storytelling the
building of the lore and the characters
like seeing kaidel continue to be used
and because she is like kind of a fan
favorite she's got this thing going on
with zavala
like there are certain characters that
they built up so well and it's people
who we didn't know of for the longest
time and then bam here's kyle and all of
a sudden we got weird lore with zaval
and kaidel
question marks of what's going on
um
no it's very cool to see a
character-like title
you guys joke about the way you are but
i was like this was like a character of
an enemy race it's insane it's all of a
sudden see now that we know this much
about them we get to see
valles forge we can you know we get to
see lord saladin just absolutely kick
everybody's butt up there
um that's seeing this type of stuff is
why i'm so excited for the story i'm
trying not to pay attention to chad so
we're just gonna i see clemson and nanu
said everything we were thinking and
yeah
it's true the only way to forge a
lasting peace is by joining the families
ivantas there you go thank you have you
have you learned nothing from game of
thrones yeah i was like i got that part
from it
she got those calves together
she does
gifts
those only calves
[Music]
it's gonna be that's where you guys will
find my pictures i am worried about it
though i am worried about because i i
really like the character i really i
want to know what a voice actress is um
i thought it was a little out of
character because
they that whole season last season was
it last season yeah risen yeah last
season they were building up the whole
like friendship and a kind of like a
little maybe a romance between caillou
and zavala and then zavala almost like
ices her to protect crow and i was like
that kind of felt a little out of
character for me i was like i don't know
isabel i don't think you like crow that
much like you probably
but i mean that's he's still he always
seems to do everything for the vanguard
he's before
yeah yeah for sure
very strong on that policy yeah
no it's just it's been a fun journey
with the story and the lore and the
characters that we're seeing but i think
the next couple of weeks are going to be
the ones that i'm most excited i mean
zavala's was
shout out to i know like hazelmontfort
on twitter she was the one the writer
who
the zavala piece that was her first
thing that she got in the game so shout
out to that one
um
i wanna see what comes next
okay everybody um
children are listening turn off the
headphones for like five seconds or mute
this go
if zabala zavala and kaidel kiss
does that mean that zavala has cabals in
his mouth
[Laughter]
i got nothing i'm just
i'm just
messy
how much did i make on this zero oh
that's zero
wonder why
wow the chat is out okay chat is uh yeah
y'all are fun um
but truly though like this is the one
title has been this through line for a
little while
yes i know we did season of lost with
savathun which had to build into witch
queen but we had
chosen before that one and then we had
risen and now kyle's still in this one
and she's gonna be the culmination of
this season she seems to be a very
important character and i think as you
said
i don't want something to happen but i
feel like as we're building this
relationship with her something might or
she's gonna have that like moment with
her facing off her facing doll is gonna
be
probably
out of coming to peace with whatever
happened there but her and callous have
to come face to face at some point that
has to happen now i don't know if that's
him as a witness and part of the story
of lightfall or something but he but
kaidel and kallus
you have to meet and i want to see that
cinematic because i actually lose my
mind
my only problem with it being kaidel and
kalas
is a callus is supposed to be
the main kind of bad guy avatar so it
feels like we would be
getting to the final boss too early in
the season you know because we don't we
still have one more season after the two
that are supposed to be title yeah i
don't think they're getting there yet i
just mean like somewhere in like the
next year that's why that's gonna happen
oh i got you're saying we're too yeah
the other thing about it being kaidel
and kalos in the next two weeks is
i don't think callus would be that
intimidating as a floating nightmare
right
but gall would be all golfing
that's my only because i don't imagine i
don't imagine this like floating pumpkin
being super scary
yeah they've already hinted that it was
gold when you when we watched the
opening cinematic it was called behind
her they gave the obvious music there
you go yeah future seasons something i
think it's better
what that means
title's got to keep this thing going so
we're going to be on this journey to see
who kyle faces and we're going to be
standing right next to her and i want to
see like zaval can you imagine if zavala
like took one for kaidal and like
sacrificed himself like if something
crazy happened man
i don't know i'm
i wasn't joking
i'll never kill him that would hit way
too hard but yeah i think he's not in a
season no you guys it's going to be an
expansion
like
fall something happens kyle's like
getting ready to face off some i don't
just like that type of moment would be
an interesting thing to see
him actually show that type of
commitment to kyle that would kind of
give all the stuff you guys are talking
about that'd be an interesting build-up
all i know like i was like i just wasn't
joking when i told tom i was just saying
i'm excited to see where the story goes
and i think as you guys were saying it's
some of the best like every tuesday all
right
it's gonna happen this week it's always
a ton of fun swab is real light zone
control uh has timers on it and
uh
this season or this weekend zone
controls and trials next week
um crucible labs is gonna be zone
control everything else is patch notes
art and movies yup swabs real light
pretty light
guys pretty light 12.
i did a good week of destiny though i
thought yeah when is one is the second
um
iron banner because i gotta do that on
my side
of course it's on the july
july 4th yeah yeah oh see that's what i
was worried about yep that's what i said
i grinded down a lot of that thing
i only
it didn't happen for me i was too
focused on it he got it teddy got it i
was busy with summer's
dude
fast finally tell y'all something that i
did to that it's ridiculous how dare you
i i can finally boast about something i
have with both of you you both decided
so yeah 1v1 me we're doing that so yeah
we actually should do some goofy things
like that a little 1v1 matches between
us actually
that could be kind of a fun goofy moment
i know what i'm going to say is uh solo
flawless duality that's done
so you were saying okay
which is her
i'll have it in july are you are you
gonna have your solo flawless
you working on it okay
yeah are you working on that solo
flawless duality next question sir
yeah that's right
i solo did it not full nice
no doubt though yeah i had like four
triumphs pop because i hadn't actually
finished the solo without being like
kicked to orbit yet so it was solo
flawless so like all of those at the
same time
i can't tell you you haven't even done
it yet dude i'll totally run yeah i've
done it yeah
i need to do it over now because that
when i when i started it we got to the
end and then we lost someone we lost i
didn't get to go but um yeah i would
yeah i would love to do that would you
because i i need it and i want to start
farming the um
i didn't know the grenade launcher i
everybody i got a good one but
it i got i got blinding grenades and
vault but which is solid
but it can run blinding grenade and
chill clip so you can slow the whole
thing and freeze them on impact and you
could you could literally get
on blinding grenades
chill clip and auto loading holster
tell me but i wish that was oh i wish
that was craftable though but yeah i got
to get in i did want to ask you guys do
you
you can farm the dungeon over and over
and over
but this whole moment where you've got
the epicurean which comes from the
dungeon which is craftable
fixed odds is craftable but they're from
the dungeon but then on the other side
you've got four weapons that
specifically aren't is that weird to
anybody else but me
not really
i don't think every weapon should be
craftable but like in the same activity
though it'd be like half the raid
weapons being craftable and half of them
not
yeah you should get a sampling of them i
think
i think it kind of depends on one like
do you need it to be craftable because
that a lot of the raid weapons are
pretty god tier if you craft the the
right version so like do are are people
really going to be like champing at the
bit for
that specific weapon to be craftable i'm
very glad that the linear fusion rifle
is craftable because that if that
weren't craftable i'd be like
so good the red ones oh my god the
dungeon that's another craft
isn't that no
no i got red frames it doesn't matter
yeah it doesn't matter yeah
it's a fake out yup yup yeah
[Laughter]
oh my god why did they put the red
frames on it i thought that magic was
craftable
get a red frame you get a red red frame
um what's the vaulted glass hand cannon
okay well
i'm with trav i feel that's a fake out
you put a red flame on it that should be
a signal you can get a red frame on
literally anything yeah is that real yes
you can get a fatebringer you can get a
red frame fatebringer it doesn't mean
you can craft one i'm committing seppaku
tonight and doing it
he was if you put bad work on that
resonance
he thought he was doing something but
three dude i cr i oh i put three storm
chasers oh yo so you don't oh no
i feel you bro somebody's like the slow
realization is priceless
[ __ ] i feel you you like yo all i gotta
do is do it
[Laughter]
we just lost traffic we launched
it so this is this is about as good as
when uh he found out about uh what you
call it um transmog material oh hey
that's been somewhat simplified at least
oh no trans moguls think of crafting um
yeah i gotta get it there though i i
yeah let me know e we gotta set it up i
need that um
[ __ ] i need that dungeon i need to
actually done it's fun yeah it's
at this point i will tell anybody who
runs do um duality if you're looking to
run it solo you're looking to run at
flawless either one of those obviously
don't
like practice it first it's going to
take you plenty of tries because i had
plenty of deaths but this season if
you've ever wanted to check the box for
triumphs for soloing or solo flawlessing
lots of things lost sectors dungeons
things of that nature
the classy restoration mod
and a healing grenade
well and a healing grenade that anyone
has access to now you have the ability
to keep yourself alive
so frequently
that it's actually really really hard
to die
it's hard to die you can die trust me
it's like that
but even in like a master lost sector i
was working on one day and it's like
it's tedious but i will tell you it's
like
you will survive you just may not output
the biggest dps but you will be able to
survive so if you can understand the
mechanics and figure those out
then it's just an endurance run because
you'll be a little slower but you should
be able to survive that's the biggest
thing
mm-hmm yeah that that bond is so good
yeah and i know we're talking about
yeah you refuse it to use it in pve i
mean that's fine
if somebody's trying to solo flawlessly
though that's where i'm going to point
them at least to help
mm-hmm
shout out to mufu
yeah met him at there as well
absolutely
yeah man i mean i get it yeah it's it's
a good weapon pool it's a good weapon
pool for sure uh the the smg man i was
just goofing around a little pvp just
for like pinnacles though
nasty
that thing feels good i like that smg
750 is always good it's just the only
issue with them is is uh stability but i
don't i heard that that one is sick
yeah it's just i don't know why i love
the look of the dungeons
absolutely and that's one of those like
a weapon designer
so oh like yeah believe me i have a
dream list of all the people i'd love to
interview a bungie but you have like the
weapon designers when they come up with
something like that i'm going damn you
gotta get some weapon designs when they
like
duality weapons
are amazing and then even like i said i
don't like now we're going to give them
some we got to be critical
vowel disciple hormone we're going to
have a talk of that team
for the titans anyway oh yeah you guys
like your titan's pretty like
that one i would want to understand
because i sit there and i look at it i'm
like you could shade it up but it's like
i want to know why when you look around
the entire pyramid
and then we get this like
kind of darkish green with like a kind
of darkish red like and then all the
little tentacles and stuff i'm like can
you just explain
where the color scheme comes from where
all the like the moving pieces that's
like i would love to understand the
journey because i know there's a reason
for some of that sometimes not just like
random colors go
i would love to understand why but they
aren't there's rolex fashion yeah it's
like it's their twist on roke
yeah we should have looked like broke at
the end like give us the red give us you
know give us that
yeah it's always it's and that's again
that would be an interesting thing to
wonder it's like
you know when you see somebody like
zolmac is always my example and you see
hey can i get dungeon armor that looks
like that they don't even have that in
eververse which is like a good example
to ask but that's always kind of an
interesting one to wonder
are you limited in the design is it like
is there a reason for a switch that was
the moon aesthetic at the time so they
went that way but it was interesting um
yeah two obs ultra light i know we got
to interview tom
yeah what else are you guys up to this
season
pretty much it for me like i said once i
get that done there's a couple of bucket
list items i have to do just to finish
off i never got parasite
like grenade
have you done the quest at all
every time i was going to start it then
i got sidetracked and i helped somebody
with dead messenger and we did dead
messenger and then we did the catalyst
for that messenger and i forgot i never
caught my parents i think you're gonna
really enjoy
the the lore and the worm because you
haven't done the quest at all have you
and i avoided all spoilers purposely
go
just go do that one because it's
actually a fun quest to
listen to like yeah definitely you know
turn up the dialogue for that one it's
all i'll say it's a fun one for sure
what about you jeff what you got um i'm
trying to catch up with
my catalyst
i think i'm only missing three i'm
missing
telesto just because i haven't gotten
the catalyst to drop yet so that's just
a matter of time
i'm missing the trespasser because i
haven't finished the quest yet and then
uh
the last one is vox obscura
dead messenger
so that one i've been trying to get my
friends to do but my friends
suck including teddy and uh they will
not do it with me i got i got the number
one guy in the chat he was a general
sinister
citizen could solo that oh no i don't
want to play with sinister he's he's a
toxic person he's toxic what's he
soloing master over there
yeah he's he's a beast he like i was
just there for the ride i'm like all
right bro
you know i got we got that done but uh
oh teddy
told you i'm like
he's getting called okay teddy teddy has
been telling me that he'll do it with me
for like three months so
his word has no stock anymore oh damn
yeah
yeah i don't have our shadow i don't
have yet though the news yeah
i got guy yilton catalyst done i did get
the catalyst yo what's up darius how you
doing man uh i got the catalyst i
haven't done it yet i need to yeah it's
nice the the cornered up close and then
the
incandescent extra
it really
leads into 3.0 it's nice that's one of
those though as soon as you see what
they can do with like incandescent
you kind of want most of the exotics to
lean into that a little more
and that's just one of those i hope they
do over time kind of add those things
too i wish i was just going to keep
sorry know what go ahead russia said i
wish i was a sniper i keep getting in uh
beloved god rolls with incandescent and
and i'm like damn i don't even snipe
like that somebody could use that
i'll be well with other stuff but yeah i
always get in that role for some reason
and apparently enhanced incandescent got
buffed so if you can craft i finally am
i'm going to be able to craft my first i
get the callous mini tool
i got that
i just got that craftable frame unlocked
i'm on like level two so that one i'll
be shooting guys with for a while that
gun now grant i don't know how it is on
controller but mouse and keyboard for a
900
man that thing is fun to use
is it good for you too
yeah it's literally the same was it good
for you i know i said that out loud i
was like oh god yeah
travis is not gonna let that go
that's not going over his head that is
definitely caught and fired back
it's gonna say family is uh what's my
joint uh the void one the uh
uh photo funnel web it's fun web family
i love nine hundreds nine i just feel
good so
so yeah callus mini tool is
legit i think i just got that one
craftable
that one actually is craftable terrible
that one i know
because i crafted it
there's dj we would tell you has low
standards though he's just happy to be a
part of it really
he's no he has no quality standards
going on
defined
second best
[Laughter]
i'll be working out until then so then
we'll be good to go
uh yeah no it's like i literally have my
first crafted weapon of the season i
feel like that's been
i haven't spent i haven't been farming
and looping you know the opulent chests
and stuff which is generally the way to
do it is just the chests
seem to be the way i get them
sorry
no i got some from nightmare some from
the opulent chests
probably some from what is it that
cause ever when you go
well nightmare containment sever and
then the opponent keys seem to be the
way i tend to get him a drop
i weird how often he's saying opulent
chests yeah anybody else feel that i i
feel that
i believe that's where you get it
i always get it from the last chest in
containment
i feel like it's a good form for me like
because for whatever reason i used to do
the witch cream stuff to try to get them
and i would never get it and then i oh i
do containment and like here you go
here's what you want i'm like all right
this is a good farm for that
it is what it is
i can't believe i can't craft storm
chaser i'm livid
so upset we we broke travis this episode
i had four or three three i had three
done oh my god oh dude they gave you
that many two
i know there's a collection i just
didn't look i just assumed
it's a good weapon i know i know where
to look i just did yeah but that's why i
asked the question is it weird that some
are and aren't craftable and now we come
back after this realization
here's the thing i feel like if you get
deep sight on it that should be a
that should be craftable but i didn't
know you could get deep sun on any i i
keep getting deep sight on the same ones
maybe that's just my luck because i kept
saying mini tool and stormchaser was
like okay these are all the ones i want
to craft so
um yeah i did not know
i just looked at my inventory and i have
one with frenzy and a couple of decent
rolls so i don't know mine haven't been
that great so far so i definitely need
to farm that one i wish i got it once
well you need to do the dungeon first
casual jesus yeah i just keep but at
least i got the the grenade launch but
yeah i'll get in there
i'll get in there
well from wants to do the dungeon after
this should we run it together
after i eat them now
all right so three hours after
the show when cog's done eating he's
thirty his thirty thousand calories to
get phoenix to keep to keep his coal
train going you gotta watch mackerel
he's gotta he's gotta shovel that coal
into the the furnace of his stomach
um
mm-hmm
let's do it i'm down look at teddy teddy
ready don't you dungeon
he's got to check one you'll be done in
no time oh
we got the first voice check first boss
you can farm all
three nice
nice honestly i've run that thing solo
so many times except maybe the opening
one
you can farm that thing so quick now
one
one
please tell me somebody knows that
i don't i think that's a local radio i
know it is like 100
i know that but if anybody else has ever
heard that yeah that would be hilarious
i know all the bay area commercials
yeah
yeah
well
we wrap this thing up here i think
that's it this has been a great episode
it's like coming home stepping in a warm
bath it's beautiful oh aries yes had a
blast at gcx
i had tom on at the start of the show
and then we were just like ripping on
each other for about the last hour
mostly at least
yeah
we had to get our unprofessionalism out
after being a professional for 30
minutes be like all right game face
game face off
man
do they play so
uh yeah chat you guys have all been
amazing thank you guys for hanging out i
know we got a little a little off thank
you for the 100 likes on the episode you
guys are fantastic thank you for the
super chats mri gamer dropping both of
them and all of you guys in chat being
here all of you for 200 plus
the lost word is where that sits i will
dig it out i will post it eventually
it's just one of those i gotta see what
it looks like
and
i will probably upload tom separately
for this one as well it may be like a
bonus for audio
and then
like for your channel as well
i'll talk to you about that afterwards
but you may see a bonus for the audio if
you listen to him there
um but yeah what do you guys got coming
up were you guys insanely excited or let
down by anything in the xbox show any
hot takes there even though i've
listened to most of yours cog already so
i know most of what you got i prefer to
travel there i haven't talked about that
so many times
yeah i've talked about it a bunch of
times too you can
check out my thoughts on the lot on um
bitcast i talked about it there but yeah
i thought it was a decent show
i think they showed some of their games
too early but i love the strategy of
only showing shows in the next 12 months
and i love the strategy of only showing
gameplay i sort of hate the whole giant
blockbuster announcements that are just
a logo and then we don't see the game
for seven years because that's right
sir are you trying to get beyond good
and evil too because that's how you get
beyond good and evil too is uh you show
the trailer way too early so um i like
their strategy um i'm interested to see
more game play other stuff i don't think
they should have showed some of the
games that were delayed that clearly
still need work and that they felt like
they
showed them anyway but i did like the
games they had to to show and i'm
excited for all of them really i like
jeff keeley's show i felt like was
really terribly paced and there was a
really weird uh commercial by the rock
in there um but yeah devolver digital
was good all those shows were cool so
i'm excited for stuff i also
are we doing are we doing personal
pitches and stuff
yeah of course um i played some of the
some of the games that were in these
shows so i got early access to some of
them so if you if your eye was caught
the jeff keeley show uh midnight fight
express i have that demo downloaded
right now
yeah so i i have played that entire game
um and it is a lot of fun and you can
read my impressions and watch a video
preview i did for it on ign.com uh
really really cool game um also i think
since the last time we had a show i did
a review for super mario strikers yep uh
battle
battle league i think it's called um so
you can read that online as well my next
review is
unknown actually don't have a review
right now but i i have a couple previews
and other stuff for games that haven't
been announced yet coming out down the
road so
you can find all that on ign.com watch
bitcast on sundays follow me on twitter
ty guy travis and uh yeah it's fun to be
back man i'm glad most of my traveling
for the years done because i hate
traveling so
that's scary as you could tell i
complained i complained to that entire
trip i was so annoying um but yeah
absolutely absolutely yeah but for me
disabled stuff um i will highly well
recommend if you guys can i really ask
but uh we had a interview with um
interior knight the developers for um as
does falls so it's kind of like an
in-person event went out there to check
them out me and solve got the interview
up on the channel right now so it's
actually a cool little formula i mean i
do i'm a sucker for like those telltale
style narrative type games yes in that
vein however what surprised me it's it
you can play it as a cooperative
multiplayer aspect of it the whole game
can be played that way and i think it's
going to do well in a party atmosphere
for people who are actually non-gamers
as well you could play um controller
phone xcloud
and it's really simple and the story is
really good it's a ton of writing ton of
narrative choices i really enjoyed it i
was it was a pleasant surprise i think
they may have something there so check
that out that is up on ireland podcast
youtube and then of course defining duke
me and matty got the impressions up of
the xbox show you want to check that out
we just recorded um the show and talked
about the whole fallout 5 situation todd
howard's comments star fields you know
that's that's the big rage now what is
star field everybody everybody has a lot
of takes there so come check it out we
find out you'll find out some very
interesting habits by maddie so go watch
that for there's another debate we got
going on the man's a savage but i love
him oh
yes
the latest
yeah
probably um
go to the section it's called let it
hang out oh dear god that pretty well
covers it
go to that section and go go judge
maddie accordingly so we got that and
then yeah i'll be this sunday should be
a big one we'll just do our aftermath
show now that we've had time to set are
any knees on the line here by the way i
never know if you guys go that big no
knees on the line but i think attic's
gonna have a lot to say because i need
to watch i guess this square show
and
apparently the square show happened
today and oh crisis core it happened
like literally not too long before the
show started yeah so i got to catch a
boat and see what's going on but yeah
man support that and it was good seeing
you boys that was fun that was a lot of
fun it was that really enjoyed the trip
definitely you guys made the trip for
sure
they saluted everybody to
the most defined in 2022 didn't get the
title but he got the most defined
uh you guys know me so i'm gonna be
working on um basically a how to solo
guide for duality that will post on
monday
um
you guys hear this one and i get it
actually posted that one's gonna have a
little sponsor so feel free to give that
an extra view
um but share that one because that's
going to be hopefully the guide for any
loadout not the exotics i've been using
so i'll be working on that one
um i did finish my solo duality flawless
run i'll figure out when i'm going to
post that one up and then i want to play
some of these demos if i can get some
time in because there's like three that
i want to play
i got a rocket demo too i want to show
you oh nakara blade pointer or whatever
it's called
yeah
uh that woo
long yeah
yeah producer bloodborne i heard and
then also it's from team ninja who did
neo and both of those games were
excellent so if it can be like and not
demon if it's not devil might cry and if
it's more souls i'm golden
so this is the problem with the
with the the current
meta when it comes to conferences is
only the games that show flashy trailers
and no gameplay get people excited and
the games that show game play they're
always like i was underwhelmed yeah
because you were expecting a big flashy
trailer like you've been seeing at every
single conference and
if people people don't understand what
is good for them they're like they want
their junk food but they should be
taking their medicine and
yeah this is this is the this is the
problem with conferences is people like
the stuff that they shouldn't like and
then are underwhelmed by this yeah
finding duke may hate me for this one
but i'm looking to forza looking forward
to forza wow yeah dude that game looks
sick no like since motorsport three
that's been my racing sim
erasing like my friends ghost and stuff
like you take like when it's a spec car
on one track and you're trying to shave
off like milliseconds versus your
friend's ghost online that's the stuff i
miss and that's what forza horizon
didn't have forza looked amazing yeah
and there was like it was a big arcade
and it's just like when i can start lord
and trust
i gave it his flowers when it after the
show
i said i know i've slandered and it's
just selfish cog because i was rising
but i get i was like bro it looked super
impressive and ray tracing in game well
that's a big deal i mean and gt botched
every micro transaction and pricing they
probably could so i was like
i tried that at my brother's house when
i visited him and i just i kept thinking
i was like do i get my simulation dude
and then i saw that this was finally
coming like
wait because yeah they botched that
they're too hard
i'm with you the one thing i will say
if god of war can drop 11 11 i'm just
gonna have a ball
i hate to break it to you
what do you think so what'd you think no
delay yes yeah well give me the inside
give us the inside that game's getting
delayed i hate to break it too
i keep seeing different things
i know well people there were
people saying that it was coming out in
november and then a lot of those same
people recanted and were like um
actually i'm hearing that maybe it isn't
going this year
this is three is gonna be dumb then
because
why why the first half of 2023 is going
to have everything the reason why is
because um
we had a two-year delay from kovid
because video game it's like movies all
got held up the year of kovid because
it's it doesn't take a ton of time to
to release a movie but the theaters had
to be open and video games had like a
delayed reaction because they were able
to finish their games but
now we're really feeling the effects of
that coveted couple you know 18 months
or so so yeah i swear february 2023 is
the same as last year i'm just gonna cry
because it's gonna be worse i know maybe
well some of those games will get
delayed again but there's gonna be some
big games that were supposed to come out
this year that are gonna come out in the
early half of next year which is to be
nuts well kalista protocol will be fun
in october so that if that makes it but
yeah dead space two and then dead space
one
all right um
we're gonna wrap it up here somehow
managed to have like two hour show even
though um got an interview on the front
of it so this will split and probably
get released in two pieces i'm gonna
have to figure out how to edit this one
out but for sure the interview for audio
i'm gonna talk with coghi once on his
channel but for all of you guys out
there thank you very much for listening
thank you here for being for this
episode and supporting us getting tom on
here if you see anything on twitter
love all of his posts for a little while
show the love to him for jumping on here
because for him to take time out of his
day
jump onto our podcast is huge so wanted
to make sure and send him massive thank
you for that one
uh but yeah gentlemen we wrapping it up
episode number 202 won't have a
palindrome for a little while
but thank you guys thank you chat and
thank you my co-host great to meet you
guys great to crush travis in our arms
travis
a little travis we're just i'm just
going to get a backpack for travis and
be like hop in next time
yeah he looked like that the picture he
took what he did like it was like a
progression he said that's how
[Laughter]
for everybody thank you guys another
great episode and this episode has been
the last word the last word
is it okay to talk now of course it is
not your recordings
no
i can tell you carlos was definitely
listening because as soon as tom ended
the call carlos sent me an email
oh wait but what'd he say what he said
last week saying
mr vibes